[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le petit joueur de flutau Menz la
musique au château pour la grâce de ses
chanson le roi lui offrit un
blason je ne veux pas être noble
répondit le
croocen avec un blason à la les mon là
se mettrait à gonfler on dirait par tout
le
pays le joueur de flû a trahi et mon
pauvre petit
clocher me semblerait trop bas perché je
ne plierai plus les
genoux devant le bon Dieu de chez nous
il faudrait à ma grand dame tous les
sains de Notre Dame avec un évêque à la
clé mon là se mettrait à gonfler on
dirait part tout le
pays le joueur de flû a
trahi je serai honte de mon sang des Aï
de qui je les sens on me vait
Boué
dessus la branche dont je suis
ISU je voudrais un
magnifique arbre
généalogique avec du sang bleu à la clé
mon là se mettrait à
gonfler on dirait partout le
pays le joueur de flû a trahi
je ne voudrais plus
épouser ma promise ma
fiancée je ne donnerai pas mon
nom à une quelconque ni non il me
faudrait pour
compagne la fille d'un grand
Espagne avec une princesse à la clé mon
l se met à
gonflé on dirait partout le
pays le joueur de Flut à
trahi le petit joueur de
flutau fit la révérence au château sans
armoirie sans
parchemin sans gloire il se mit en
chemin vers son clocher sa chemine
ses parents et sa
promise nul ne disent dans le
pays le joueur de Flut a trahi et Dieu
reconnaiss pour
sien le brave petit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
musicien yeah